las imágenes que salen hoy de irán e
irak en el la conmemoración del
aniversario del asesinato no solamente
el general iraní qasem soleimani sino
también de quien fuera el segundo de las
llamadas milicias hazard xavi un frente
de movilización popular en irak abu al
mojantes no puede ser más diferente como
consecuencia del cobi 19 y las medidas
que se toman en irán donde la mayoría de
ceremonias se han llevado de manera de
manera virtual a solamente un par
presenciales con muy poca participación
y el resto de afiches y imágenes de casa
en su alemán y para recordar su imagen
en el resto de las ciudades mientras
tanto en irak han habido grandes
demostraciones la primera de ellas
anoche la vía al aeropuerto de bagdad
donde fueron asesinados el pasado 3 de
enero y esta mañana se repite lo mismo
en la gran plaza de tahrir especialmente
con milicianos que pertenecen a esas
milicias comandadas no solamente por
almirantes sino también por casi en su
ley man y esto se da en un
en el que la tensión entre eeuu se irán
está en uno de sus momentos máximos
ambos países tenían un ataque contrario
y eeuu había mandado en las últimas
semanas bombarderos b-52 y también un un
submarino nuclear a la región e irán
también estaba en máxima alerta pero al
parecer todo parece tranquilo hasta el
momento como lo pudimos recordar y pero
hoy en las calles de teherán donde la
población no parece estar pensando en
eso sino más bien en la gran
contaminación que hay en la ciudad
especialmente en teherán en el día de
hoy